hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
now we're joining our family once again
you've had Yoshi Len he got in Max and
Max might be my favorite but I hope he
doesn't tell anybody else about that but
I don't think favourites are going to
matter because we might all be dead very
soon
there is poisonous oxygen gas seeping in
throughout our entire base they're
frozen in stasis here don't mind but not
only that we're also not producing
enough of our own oxygen and there's a
food shortage and I don't know where
these mealworms are going to come
through but yeah it's not going to be
very good for us but I'm not going to
give up
ohana means family and you don't give up
on your family so I'm going to persevere
and I'm going to try to make sure these
guys survive
sorry event you were kind of a newcomer
and we don't have a bed for you just yet
but either way we got a new night cycle
to get through listen to discover what
we're actually going to do here and I'm
pretty sure they're all choking on the
contaminated oxygen which has gone very
far down here so we may have to dig this
way but there's poisonous chlorine gas
over there that's going to definitely
kill us if we go over there so there's
got to be a way we have to go up and I
and I just discovered that you can
actually build a ladder up which I did
not know before but I'm going to build a
ladder right there I don't know how I'm
gonna build this hopefully unreachable
well once you build a ladder it won't be
so unreachable now will it okay so
hopefully they're going to do that and
then put these up to priority nine good
Sam they need to do something because we
got to get out of here cuz if we can't
survive the gas here then we're going to
have a problem oh my god that is - oh my
god how the hell did that happen that
was just over one night Jesus
that's not good I don't even know how
we're gonna be able to have enough Cydia
and I thought we did these is going bad
for us but we're not gonna give up I'm
not gonna give up on the boys I know
that they're worth it they're just okay
we do okay I could have sworn that we
got the pity and out of it so if they
build those and then they climb up here
and then they dig a new way through here
there's a vacuum there but there is
oxygen down here not a lot there's not a
lot of oxalate left but probably because
that whole place is saturated but if we
dig through here this could be a new
home for us and we've got we've got
algae there that we could definitely use
and hopefully with that we'll be able to
continue upwards spread this good oxygen
that way and then I don't know these
guys are just wallowing in the Hornets
are they hungry
it's gonna be like the last bit that we
could possibly eat mmm everyone's gonna
be dead soon come on how many how much
why is it so much contaminated oxygen I
think what happens is it it just it
poisons everything it touches
there's no no way to get out of it
it just converts all the other oxygen
into poisonous gas and frankly this was
doing me a favor but that that storage
compactor is just bad news and they're
not doing well but I know my boys are
going to survive I know this for a fact
so what we're going to do they just all
got a meal so we're going to deconstruct
everything we got to start over I'm
sorry guys this is the way that it's got
to be we got to move we got to go if
we're going to survive we got to go
somewhere we've never been before so how
about you guys
you
they're all getting poisoned aren't they
that's fun I good max come on you were
my favorite all right sue they're gonna
be doing that tub and hopefully we can
get out of here
yeah yeah yeah max is not looking too
good
I don't know why max is spreading the
spores everywhere but I'm pretty sure
that means he's sick
so our back no oxygen he's bad come on
guys get up there go there please let's
go there you can do it you can survive
all right max get out of there next what
are you doing it let's get up Oh max can
dig I forgot okay so max needs to build
something good god that contaminated
oxygen spread everywhere how did you do
that why does it contaminate absolutely
everything that it touches oh man
okay so I got to build something up
there we got to get new beds at least
least I can do that for them maybe a bad
start out here they got the rest of
these things build more beds I guess
what he gets doing it oh they're getting
supplies
Oh aren't you brave going into the
contaminated oxygen like that all right
so we got a little going to build out
you and then at least I know how to
build ladders now so that's okay all
right so what we're going to do is we're
going to wall this off oh no we can't
use of the materials okay well the gases
spread pretty far but it's pretty thin
per square meter so I think it's going
to be okay I care about these guys want
them to be alright and they're going to
be okay
she's got to make sure the big move you
just got to make sure keep going all
right looking good looking good guys
looking good just watch out for the
horrors that await you over there and
there's oxygen up there I'm assuming Oh
me wood okay oh [ __ ] carbon dioxide
carbon dioxide oh no no no no don't do
that
no hang on wait what just happened why
did that happen probably right here at
the doorway I'm hoping that's going to
work out better
so that'll provide a little bit of
oxygen it'll also offset the a little
bit of the okay that's gonna help it's
going to offset the carbon dioxide
because that's that's building up a lot
I want all these to be priority nine all
right we should have some algae over
here that'll be able to help out man at
least at least the toxic gas isn't
absolutely killing him Gus get to oxygen
I know I know it's bad I know it's bad I
know it's real bad the situation is
about as bad as it can possibly get but
you guys can do it you can survive you
do this maybe probably not believe those
are going to get some algae because I
know that we got some algae here well
narcoleptic Josie just passed out Josie
it's okay you are who you are oh boy
Jesus can dire yes
that's what we were looking for we're
looking for them to start producing
oxygen and get rid of the carbon dioxide
because that's what's killing us all
right now what's going on
now see for that tooth jeez oh jeez oh
come on
sleeping is really not the best bet
right now oh boy oh boy
well if they're not dead ah man I really
everyone else is doing wonderfully
it's just Lenny that feel stressed I
don't know why yeah the event keeps
having to get up in the middle of the
night to breathe kind of hard to believe
but I think we might actually turn this
around
it looks dire it looks really dire oh
god I forgot to build up wired about
okay build that all right you're doing
good there we're going to build a ladder
straight to the moon eventually we're
going to build a ladder straight up but
can you build true rock for the ladder
because that would be super cool uh-huh
I can't believe it but this is pushing
the the poisonous contaminated oxygen
over there
ish honey I shouldn't have killed puff
this is definitely my punishment I know
that for a fact
yeah so they're doing okay so things
aren't the worst that they've ever been
they're pretty bad but a lot of the
contaminated gas is being pushed out I
mean there's still a lot of it and these
are dealing with the carbon dioxide as
they can but we don't have algae we need
grow pods for just algae and I'm
thinking that I could probably use this
as storage because for some reason
there's a bit of pocket of oxygen in
here but if I if I build planter box
we're still out of food I just forgot
about that okay so there is meal wood
there [ __ ] I got rid of the planter oh
man I don't even know if that's ready to
harvest we got to build okay I know it's
not fun I know it's not fun but we got
to build those uh dirt the dirt
literally the dirt we got to build that
all right let's do this we got a huh I'm
not gonna let him starve but we're out
of food so that means ooh we got to do
what we got do and that means we got to
make mush
make mush bars we got to make a lot of
mush bars and it's gonna cause a lot of
diarrhea we don't have access to water I
just remembered that all right well
we're going to deconstruct this wall
here and then they're going to have
access to water and then they're going
to go through that and do that and that
thing is still going to make more
contaminated oxygen I cannot believe how
much that slime producers like that is
unbelievable
oh no I didn't need to do that god damn
it I didn't need to do that I need to
block that off again
I don't want them to be blocked off
there though damn it god damn it oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh don't block
yourself and there are you [ __ ]
stupid Matt I go over there stop being
there go over there okay now build a
goddamn wall and then build a ladder
straight down to the water which I don't
know why I didn't even think about that
I also put it in the wrong place
whoa god damn it my [ __ ] light why
not I've been quite a night okay I know
this has been a little crazy and I'm not
too happy about the way things have gone
goddamnit close the wall now got you it
- got you [ __ ] at it guts move your
ass
move your ass get out of there you son
of a [ __ ] just build it Nash come back
[ __ ] build it max stop taking a [ __ ]
and go build it I know you're hungry I
know you are oh yeah okay there we go
[ __ ] wait no what just build it why
are you cleaning the toilet right now
[ __ ] built no building bag are you
[ __ ] kidding me
but help a goddamn wall I can't believe
this
I cannot believe this oh my god oh my
god
build a wall build a wall buildable Wow
oh my god oh my god oh my [ __ ] god
build a [ __ ] wall Hills a [ __ ]
wall build a [ __ ] wall
fill it [ __ ] building someone come
build it you better than a beat building
that you're bad you [ __ ] idiot
what are you doing it what are you guys
doing Gus stop what are you doing you
[ __ ] idiot
just [ __ ] build the [ __ ] wall no
don't cancel it god damn it no don't
don't stop max get out of there just
build it build it there we go finally
god damn it finally you're back oh and I
know everyone is stressed cuz they're
just eating mush bars like I know that
for a fact
yo yo yo yo uh yeah yo yo yo yo I'm not
happy I'm not happy with my children
right now not happy with it
I don't like it I don't want to like it
I'm not gonna like it
uh yah yah yah yah yah yah okay
it looks like the breathing situation is
doing a little bit better up there which
is kind of nice it is nice it is nice
yeah I know
one of your buddy smells real bad okay
so now that we had that little family
turmoil oh God
let's bring a new family member in here
olive quick learner mole hands Nite Owl
and a mouth breather so she makes she
takes up more oxygen but she seems to
have a lot of really great skills I'm
gonna bring in olive olive please help
us please help us
olive please I know we're in bad
situation we're in a bad situation we
can't let that bring us down we have to
be this is just going to push
contaminated oxygen towards this with no
maybe not maybe it's that going to act
like a filter like this water is a
natural filter okay so we're doing
better here we've got a path up this way
so what we got to do is we got to
harvest all this algae we need this
stuff here and then this is clay which
is cultivatable soil and that's nice
what we can also do yeah I know I know
it's bad everyone's stressed especially
Lenny I get it even all of his stress
and she just got here I get it I can
forgive you that all of you please guide
these people you're a natural leader
you can do this olives I believe in you
you and me together we're gonna get
through this I know we can I know we can
and max I know you try you're still my
favorite but you've just got a got to do
a little more fun please I need to make
it storage okay so we need it up that's
what we need converts lime into algae we
need a bio distiller ah so we need to
research percolation so we got to get
our research back up and ready to go
which means we got to put it over here
that's going to be good okay we're gonna
put it over here so we need a new power
generator right there we're gonna get a
new battery right there we're going to
get two batteries we're gonna really
keep this key fit system up someone's
going to be running on that a whole lot
of whole lotta so now that we got that
we're gonna need stations we're gonna
need a research station we're gonna need
to research stations because that's this
kind of people we are you're giving up I
ain't giving up on my family and they're
not gonna give up on me probably could
because if they give up that means their
dad that's okay so we're gonna need a
medical cot - we're gonna put that right
over there right there
we got it mush bars bad I know they suck
but we can deal with it
goddamn it there are beds up here Jesus
and you get just deconstruct these beds
I guess now I guess it's fine they'll
sleep wherever they want to sleep even
if they breathe contaminated air all
right come on you peaceful bastards wake
up we got work to do get a move on it
you [ __ ] huh all right so we've got a
long way to go we got to do these
research stations they're going to be
good we need to build more stuff
probably the super computer is something
that also needs to be built we might
need to fill more manual generators
other than what we got right there but
that should be okay because so long as
we got what we need we're going to we're
going to be able to survive this there's
very little contaminated oxygen that's
made its way up here and my guys are
actually acting as filters themselves
with their bodies and you know the human
body is a great filter that's how it
should be used right and then they're
going to be okay
so percolation that was not it was
actually my next one percolation was it
because biota Silla can finally get rid
of that slime once and for all and
that's what we got to do whoa Gus oh my
god Gus you smelly bastard we need like
some sort of uh create a shower of some
sort well we need sanitation science to
be able to do that sanitation science
sounds important where the heck is that
it's not even on this little there it is
air deodorizer Oh filtering contaminated
oxygen out of the air oh that sounds
great I didn't see that Oh get that next
okay I'll get that next I know I know I
know it's all bad I know it's all bad
socks everything here's fine everything
is awful we're all dying I get it all
right so the super come on finish the
supercomputer come on finish it finish
it I know Gus god damn it you smell so
bad but it's okay I believe in you okay
intermediary research we need to build
that forever which just means water
which just means people need to go get
water which just means
you'd actually build a ladder that
connects these two that'd be smart I'm
going to prioritize that highly so that
people have a route just to go to the
water in that way we're not just going
back and forth all the time that might
bring up some contaminated oxygen but
hopefully when we get the purifier all
settled we'll be okay I'm gonna build
this area out is like another another
another research area so that we have
double layered here and eventually I'll
build like a room and whatnot but maybe
later oh yeah cycle 10 report ready what
does a me is it bad
yeah it's bad alright it's pretty bad
but at least it seems to be going okay
Lenny is no longer the most stress that
we got here okay so we got that going on
oh we got to get this going the
supercomputer but hopefully that won't
take much longer in the next cycle okay
we're almost through the woods we're
almost through the darkness the darkness
was scary
we'll get it come on keep researching
you got it you bet I believe in you as
they dig this out you keep you keep a
chuckling be perfect perfect okay that's
good they got that so now they're gonna
direct path to the water it's good we
got you max doing research now that's
good
how much more do we need we need eight
more okay keep going guys priority nine
your computer is super priority we're
gonna fix you
we're going to fix you your slime
batches we're going to cut off the
source of the slime first and then we're
going to cut off the [ __ ]
contaminated oxygen we're going to get
it here in here we're going to get it so
pure okay I just prioritize some algae
getting up there so once they get that
that'll be a little bit better we've got
plenty of water come on come on we need
more research we need more research
we're close oh one more come on you got
this guys you got this come on I believe
in you I believe in you
please yes all of yes do it please Oh
God all of yes okay yes all right we got
that so that's good so now that we have
that we've got Wu electrolyzer Mick
doxygen from water that's actually
really handy so then we need where was
it where was it
water if you appar off by Oh distiller
this is what we needed so with the bio
distiller I don't even think it needs
doesn't it doesn't even seem to need
power so we're going to make this top
priority next cycle obviously because
they're all sleeping and then we're
going to get rid of the goddamn slime so
we need to unleash that for now but then
we're going to get rid of the goddamn
slime that slime is going away forever
and with it all this [ __ ] that's
been playing in us since I killed puck
once that's gone I'll be able to live
our lives come on come on guys build it
up build it up build it up bill bill
bill go go yogi go go yogi
go yogi go yogi you got it good job yogi
okay oh it does need power god damn it I
didn't know that right so we'll just
build we'll just do it like this I it's
not pretty but we'll just do like this
all right
um 34 times for the nine moved a bit of
poop oh okay go go for it go go go
priority 1
oh man I need to stop abusing the
priority Donna not today not today
oh oh oh it's doing it oh I don't know
how it's doing it but it's doing it I
don't know what we're doing but we did
it oh I think we did it huh
we did it and we got a new guy Oh red
i'll me seek if your decorator iron gut
bottom of suck and biohazard nah yo cool
not very smart can't be researched I'm
okay with that
he's got twinkle toes all right I'm
gonna go with meat cuz I like the name
alright meat come on out okay
missing foundation missing foundation
now god damn it okay so that's missing a
foundation so now we gotta build that
out there alright that's gonna be
priority 9 again I think it's okay
because I think that piping did go
through the tile I'm pretty sure but I
think it's working I think it's finally
getting rid of the slime and once it
gets rid of the slime everything is why
have I not been researching I'm an idiot
sanitation Sciences I'm an idiot but
once that's done then the slime is gone
and then no more will we have
contaminated oxygen in my base I've
saved you [ __ ] you've saved you I put
you in the situation but you saved me
saved you alright
I love you good this climate so anyway
that's the end of this episode I've got
a long way to go before I even get
remotely close to surviving here I don't
even know what's happening there that is
weird okay but either way I think I'm
all done here we've accomplished a lot
and I don't know what exactly we're
going to do but we're going to try our
best to get there so contaminated water
is that from the contaminated oxygen I
bet it is but either way we're doing
pretty good so thank you everybody so
much for watching I hope you enjoying
this
I certainly am this is it Yugi this dude
Mugen thank you everybody so much for
watching it and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]